[Musik]
willkommen zum schlagabtausch nach dem
tv duell der kandidaten von union und
sozialdemokraten vorhin treffen hier und
jetzt die spitzenkandidaten der anderen
im bundestag vertretenden parteien
aufeinander
eine stunde lang geht es zur sache und
um die sache damit positionen und
gegensätze sehr klar werden dazu begrüße
ich hier in berlin im studio nicola beer
von der fdp
und wenn wir hier die linke
und wir für die afd die eu als
friedensprojekt dafür gibt es viel
zustimmung aber es gibt das wollen wir
nicht verhehlen auch in dieser sendung
auch viel skepsis gegenüber der eu viele
fragen sich zum beispiel das soll das
ganze mit dem europaparlament die
entscheidungen werden doch sowieso ganz
woanders getroffen und gerne hinter
verschlossenen türen
seit zehn jahren frau keller sind sie
europa abgeordnete kennen das ganze von
innen warum sollte man wählen
und was kann das parlament man sollte
wählen gehen weil wirklich jede stimme
und jeder abgeordnete einen großen
unterschied macht im europäischen
parlament treffen wir oft entscheidungen
die sich nur mit einer stimme mehrheit
entscheiden oder auch mal mit 510
stimmenmehrheit es macht also ein
unterschied wen auch immer mal ins
parlament schickt und man sollte sich
genau aussuchen für welche partei man
die stimme abgepasst gibt doch sehr
große unterschiedlich es gibt parteien
die wollen die europäische union
abschaffen
man gibt solche die man einfach nur so
weitermachen aber als grüne denken wir
dass wir die europäische union brauchen
weil alle herausforderung unserer zeit
müssen wir im europäischen verbund
angehen sonst können wir viel zu wenig
erreichen aber wir müssen auch die
europäische union verändern damit wie
sich stärken könnte da kommen wir noch
zu seit eineinhalb jahren ist auch jörg
merten europaabgeordneter er sagt von
sich selbst jörg allein zu haus weil die
anderen sechs afd abgeordneten aus der
partei ausgetreten sind
jetzt hoffen sie auf verstärkung wollen
das parlament aber abschaffen warum weil
wir glauben dass im europäischen
parlament nicht die zentralen
entscheidungen getroffen werden staaten
haben parlamente und die institution
parlament spricht für eine einrichtung
eines europäischen superstaat es an dem
arbeiten alle anderen außer uns auch
vergemeinschaftung der haushaltspolitik
gemeinsame steuern gemeinsame
außenpolitik gemeinsame
sicherheitspolitik das läuft auch die
vereinigten staaten von europa hinaus
und wenn wir die hätten mehr rein
parlament richtig aber für die
vertretung von nationen für die wir
stehen für ein europa der vaterländer da
brauchen wir kein eigenes parlament wir
brauchen den rat und die kommission die
aber deutlich schlanker das heißt da
sind viel zu viele menschen mit viel zu
vielen aufgaben beschäftigt der weiß
nicht bedarf auch bei der linken gibt es
vier
der eu skeptiker aber so weit würden sie
dann doch nicht gehen das parlament
abschaffen zu wollen also wir wollen
gerechtigkeit wende in der europäischen
union durch die wollen eine andere
politik machen die haben festgestellt
dass der europäische binnenmarkt in den
vergangenen jahren missbraucht wurde
für lohndumping und steuerdumping und
wir sagen wir wollen was anderes
erreichen
aber wie die afg die demokratie
abschaffen nein um gottes willen nicht
das europaparlament ist wichtig sagt
auch nicola beer weil auf jeden fall
deswegen weil es die vertretung der
bürgerinnen und bürger in europa ist ich
möchte nicht wie heute nur ein europa
der regierungen der institution ich
möchte ein europa der menschen
und deswegen ist es gut dass wir diese
direktwahl haben deswegen können
menschen gerade jetzt bei dieser
europawahl die chance nutzen dass er
eine andere mehrheit kriegen haben die
letzten 40 jahre quasi eine große
koalition gehabt jetzt ist es möglich
diese kurse koalition diesen stillstand
aufzubrechen wir möchten eine
modernisierungs allianz schaffen
und deswegen ist es diesmal noch
wichtiger zur wahl zu gehen als aldi
allemal davor so viel mal zum
grundsätzlichen was europa und das
parlament betrifft da hat man schon sehr
deutliche unterschiede zwischen ihnen
vier gesehen
wir haben übrigens einen faktencheck am
start die kolleginnen und kollegen
überprüfen strittige fragen und aussagen
aus dieser sendung die ergebnisse können
sie heute oder spätestens morgen
nachlesen auf heute.de es gibt skepsis
bei vielen bürgern auch enttäuschung
auch wut und das ist mit der
flüchtlingskrise der letzten jahre
schlimmer geworden
wie umgehen mit den menschen die hier
schutz suchen oder auch einen weg aus
der armut das diskutieren wir sofort
nach einem kurzen einspielfilm der uns
bilder und fakten in erinnerung ruft
[Musik]
spätestens seit der flüchtlingskrise
2015 ist klar eine gemeinsame
europäische migrations und asylpolitik
gibt es nicht stattdessen streiten die
mitgliedsländer noch immer erbittert
über die verteilung der schutzsuchenden
während länder wie italien und
griechenland auf entlastung bringen weil
vor allem die osteuropäischen staaten
keine flüchtenden aufnehmen
auch pläne für eine gemeinsame
grenzpolizei oder eine europäische
asylbehörde konnten bislang nicht
realisiert werden
die mittelmeer mission sofia gilt nach
der blockade durch die italienische
regierung als faktisch gescheitert die
grenzschutzagentur frontex oft als
handlungsunfähig dass 2018 nur noch etwa
116.000 flüchtende über das mittelmeer
gekommen sind liegt vor allem an
umstrittenen deals mit der türkei und
libyen
das risiko auf der flucht zu sterben
aber hat sich seither mehr als
verfünffacht europäische
flüchtlingspolitik so kritisieren
menschenrechtler setzte nur noch auf
abwehr und nehme das leiden billigend in
kauf
[Musik]
die anzahl der menschen die über das
mittelmeer flüchten
die ist in den letzten jahren drastisch
gesunken die afg schreibt in ihrem
programm das die migrationspolitik ich
zitiere die europäische zivilisation in
existenzielle gefahr bringt ist das
angesichts dieser sinkenden zahlen nicht
zumindest mal krass übertrieben
ja wenn ich von der basis 2015 ausgehe
ist es logischerweise sinken wir können
aber auch nicht übersehen dass wir immer
noch eine deutlich höhere zahl an
migranten haben die hineinkommen als
solche die weder verabschiedet werden
die migration steigt immer weiter
und daran ändert dass überhaupt nichts
lassen sie mich zu der mittelmeer
problematik vielleicht folgen ich sagen
es gibt zwei möglichkeiten die tod im
mittelmeer zu vermeiden das eine ist wir
machen die menschen die grenzen
vollständig auf lassen alle reihen
dann wird europa in zehn jahren völlig
anders aussehen und ich glaube niemand
will dass die andere möglichkeit ist das
ist das was sie mit der gefahr meine das
ist das was wir mit der gefahr meinen
und dafür stehen ja hier die grünen
stehen dafür die linke stehen dafür die
wollen die grenzen restlos aufmachen die
andere möglichkeit den tod im mittelmeer
zu vermeiden ist wir machen
seenotrettung bringen die menschen aber
konsequent an die gestartet zurück wo
sie aufgebrochen sind
wenn wir das sechs wochen acht wochen
durchhalten wird kein mensch mehr diese
route wählen wird niemand mehr trinken
das ist jay jay politik der australier
lieber hoch erfolgreich vor der
australischen küste seit jahren jemand
ertrunken können wir hier problemlos
auch realisieren muss man machen jetzt
ist alles und man grünen direkt
angesprochen gewesen und sollen auch die
chance haben dazu stellung also ich
finde es tatsächlich ein skandal dass im
moment tagtäglich menschen im mittelmeer
stelle sterben und die europäische union
dabei zuschaut und man packt hat
präsident erdogan der die menschenrechte
selber mit füßen tritt oder libyschen
warlords zusammenarbeitet wir wissen
tatsächlich dass die
menschenrechtssituation in libyen alles
andere als gutes und dass menschen die
dorthin zurückgeführt werden im moment
auch brutaler gewalt oder zum teil auch
vergewaltigung stattfinden von männern
wie frauen und ich weiß dass die afg nun
wirklich nichts mit menschlichkeit zu
tun hat aber ich sage folgendes wenn
viele menschen in deutschland sich im
moment mit der europäischen union
identifizieren europa positiv betrachten
dann weil sie es verbinden mit werten
die humanit
aufklärung fortschrittliche werte und im
moment werden diese werte mit füßen
getreten ich finde es einen skandal ich
will es ändern
ich will eine solidarische
migrationspolitik durchsetzen und
tatsächlich fluchtursachen bekämpfen
weil man muss zur wahrheit sagen dass
natürlich auch waffen aus deutschland
frankreich aus der europäischen union
mit zum leid der menschen beitragen oder
die freihandelsverträge jetzt nicht die
soziale situation in den ländern
verbessert haben und der klimawandel ist
ja auch ein grund warum immer mehr
menschen fliehen müssen und das leid
wird die eiche ja sogar ich glaube
worauf wir alle uns schnell einigen
können ist das eine dramatische
situation ist die wir da im mittelmeer
erleben seit jahren vor keller was sagen
denn die grünen wie kann man das lösen
ja unser blick auf flüchtlinge auf
migration unterscheidet sich in der tat
fundamental von dem der fc und anderen
rechtsnationalen weil wir sehen
flüchtlinge als menschen mit
menschenrechten als menschen wie wir
alle sind und ich kann es nicht
akzeptieren dass wir 2009 10 in der
europäischen union einer union die sich
auf menschenrecht auf werte gegründet
hat eine situation haben wo menschen im
mittelmeer ertrinken will wissen wo sie
sind aber niemand hilft die staaten
helfen nicht und die menschen die ngo s
die helfen wollen
die werden von ländern wie italien
aufgehalten deren schiffe werden
konfisziert und jetzt soll sie auch noch
mit strafzahlungen belegt werden das ist
nicht meine europäische union
ich will eine europäische union der
humanität der menschenrechte egal wo
auch vor der eigenen haustür und wir
wollen dass es endlich eine europäische
seenotrettung gibt dass wir diese
sterben nicht länger einfach so
akzeptieren
die menschen die menschen die dann
gerettet werden wohin kommen die dann
hatten recht wenn man ihnen sagt sie
wollen alle reinholen unsere europäische
flüchtlingspolitik muss ich darauf
gründet dass wir zu allererst
fluchtursachen bekämpfen niemand
verlässt freiwillig seine heimat die
menschen verlassen die heimat wegen
krieg wegen sozialen ungleichheiten wird
tragen dazu bei indem wir zum beispiel
waffen exportieren zweitens brauchen wir
dringend seenotrettung aber auch legale
und sichere fluchtwege damit in der tat
menschen die internationalen schutz
brauchen den auch bekommen und wir
brauchen eine europäische asylpolitik
mit geordneten verfahren mit gleichen
asyl chancen und wir brauchen eine
solidarische faire verteilung auf alle
mitgliedstaaten wo es ab wofür es auch
schon bereits breite mehrheiten gibt im
europäischen parlament schon seit vielen
vielen jahren sagen wir im europäischen
parlament fraktionsübergreifend wie es
laufen sollte
leider liegen uns die mitgliedstaaten da
immer wieder steine im weg auch die
bundesregierung übrigens hat schon 2013
gegen eine neue ordnung oder gegen eine
fairen solidarische verteilung bestimmt
das fällt uns jetzt auf die füße da
müssen wir dringend daran arbeiten
freizügigkeit
freizügigkeit das ist ja auch ein
zentraler grundpfeiler der eu so steht
es auch im wahlprogramm der fdp frau wer
was machen sie daraus in bezug auf die
situation im mittelmeer oder auch an der
deutsch österreichischen grenze also die
situation im mittelmeer zeigt dass das
eigentlich ein gerät das größte versagen
der europäischen union nicht nur seit
2015 sondern schon in den jahren davor
ist dass wir keine gemeinsame
migrationspolitik in europa haben meines
erachtens funktioniert es nur so dass
wir klar unterscheiden und zwar zwischen
der politischen oder religiösen
verfolgung weil keiner in europa das
gehört einfach zur grundlage unserer
werte möchte jemand nicht schützen der
was weiß ich als chinesischer dissident
oder als verfolgter buddhist muslim oder
christ hier bei uns aufnahme sucht dann
haben wir die gruppe die auch
völkerrechtlich geschützte ist wo wir
auch hermann schlicht auch uns
solidarisch zeigen müssen bei dem die
aus kriegssituationen
bürgerkriegssituation fliehen habe ich
noch jede rüstung für und weise ich habe
leute die ihren hasen weise befristet
schutz suchen
aber das größte problem der europäischen
union ist dass sie eben den dritten teil
und das sind die größeren anzahl an den
dritten teil der aus anderen gründen die
legitim sind dass wir da keine regelung
haben nämlich einwanderungsrecht in
unseren arbeitsmarkt da brauchen wir ein
punktesystem
da müssen wir klar auch als
gesellschaften hier in der lage sein zu
definieren welche anforderungen wir
stellen an die die wir einladen nämlich
in unseren arbeitsmarkt nicht in unsere
sozialsysteme und wie viel wir einladen
das müssen die mitgliedsstaaten selber
definieren können ich glaube dann könnte
man mit so einer lösung eben streit
vermeiden könnte auch klarstellen dass
wir die eu-außengrenzen dann
entsprechend eben gemeinsam schützen
nämlich europäisch die länder am rande
der eu nicht alleine lassen damit
binnengrenzen offen sind weil ich will
keine schlagbäume mehr wie jetzt in
bayern
das sind maßnahmen genau deswegen haben
wir diese europäische union geschaffen
damit wir diesen inneren freiraum haben
dass wir offene grenze nach innen haben
aber das bedeutet dann eben auch nach
draußen klar zu definieren was sind die
regeln nach denen wir her kommen dürfen
was stellen wir verantwortung und das
heißt eben auch an diejenigen die kommen
weil sie hier etwas aufbauen wollen dass
sie auch selber mit dazu tun müssen und
die dieses system ist brauchen zum
beispiel durch kriminalität oder anderes
dass wir denen auch sagen müssen sorry
das sind nicht unsere regeln dann geht
es eben auf die theorie
die eu will ja die grenzschutzagentur
frontex stärken das wollen sie von der
fdp auch die linke will das nicht
wir sind diejenigen die das element
ablehnen war gerne da sagen die
aufrüstung an den europäischen aber was
ist die alternative frau demirel wenn
sie gerne rad fahren oder sie holen die
menschen aus dem wasser
und sie können sie nicht nach malta oder
italien weil die ihre häfen dicht machen
wo ist dann die lösung des problems also
wenn sie ernsthaft lösungen des problems
suchen wollen dann sage ich ihnen dann
lassen sie uns über die europäischen
handels verträge zum beispiel reden die
in afrika im moment lokale märkte
zerstören lassen sie uns darüber reden
dass die europäische union im moment die
afrikanischen küsten er fisch und
dadurch zum beispiel fischerinnen und
fischer vor ort keine lebensgrundlage
mehr haben oder lassen sie uns darüber
reden was gerade die eu agrarpolitik
auch in den afrikanischen staaten für
die landwirte bedeutet sie reden ja
gerade über diejenigen die von sozialen
schieflagen betroffen sind aus sozialen
nöten hierher kommen warum müssen zum
beispiel hühner teile auf europa
geliefert werden nach afrika das ist
nicht gut für die menschen dort weil
ihre lebensgrundlagen zerstört werden
sozial zerstört werden es ist nicht gut
für unsere umgehängt im grunde alles mit
allem zusammen sorgen sie wenn die
wirtschaft mit den grundlagen dort im
stadtbezirk ich bin selber tochter einer
politischen flüchtlings familie
ich habe unter politischen situation in
der türkei beziehungsweise meine eltern
haben gelitten und wir sind deshalb
gekommen aber ich finde es zynisch wenn
im moment darüber geredet wird als ob
die menschen aus heiterem himmel fliehen
würden ich kann ihnen versichern kein
mensch nimmt diese route mittelmeer oder
überhaupt die flucht aufsicht weil ihm
gerade langweilig ist aber wenn bomben
auf jemanden fallen wenn die existenzen
zerstört sind wenn man kinder hat und
keine lebensgrundlage mehr hat dann
frage ich mich selber was würde ich
machen
und natürlich würde ich versuchen meinen
kindern die beste situation zu schaffen
und deshalb finde ich immer sehr wichtig
was auch jean ziegler gesagt hat es geht
nicht darum unbedingt zb den ärmeren
ländern immer nur mehr zu geben
es geht aber auch darum irgend weniger
zu nehmen und im moment nimmt
deutschland und auch die europäische
union den ländern viel an
lebensgrundlage und das muss sich ändern
und solange sich das nicht ändert ist es
so dass man eine verantwortung dafür
trägt das sind
in der lage sein wieder aufzunehmen und
noch eine zahl vielleicht zum schluss in
der europäischen union leben etwa 500
millionen menschen
wir reden in höchstzeiten von
geflüchteten also es wird ja immer von
diesen wellen gesprochen sagen wir mal
ungefähr 2016 sind um die 1,3 millionen
menschen die neuen asylantrag
hergestellt haben bekommen also wenn 500
millionen menschen nicht in der lage
sind etwa 1,3 bis 1,5 millionen menschen
aufzunehmen
dann müssen wir über ganz andere da sind
wir genau bei dem spiel
da würde ich ja den magen der tiere
rechnung funktion funktioniert ja nur
wenn alle sich gleichermaßen beteiligen
und frau keller sie haben es ja vorher
auch schon gesagt dass sie solidarisch
ist europäisches asylsystem wünschen
würden aber ist das nicht wunschdenken
wenn man sich mal ungarn polen oder
italien real ansieht also ich frage mich
immer schon warum wir es denn im
europäischen parlament geschafft haben
mehrheiten zu organisieren bei uns
sitzen genau dieselben parteien aus
denselben ländern wie es auch bei den
mitgliedsstaaten sitzen und wir schaffen
es eine mehrheit zu organisieren wird
fraktionsübergreifend alle waren dafür
aus der csu und die mitgliedstaaten
kriegen das nicht hin woran liegt das
eigentlich genau trotzdem habe ich
müssen wir uns jetzt überlegen wir was
machen wir jetzt wie gehen wir jetzt
voran
und da sollten sich die mitgliedstaaten
die vorangehen wollen
dies zumindest sagen auch dann nicht
hinter orban zum beispiel verstecken
sondern sie können bereits jetzt
zusammen vorangehen als zehn staaten 15
statt 20 dabei auch immer die gemeinsam
vorangehen wollen die können sagen okay
wir machen das jetzt im rahmen der
verstärkten zusammenarbeit also ein
instrument was völlig normales unter dem
europäischen recht wird öfter eingesetzt
da könnten die mitgliedsstaaten
vorangehen und jetzt schon mal zeigen es
funktioniert ja viele osteuropäische
staaten weigern sich ja seit jahren
flüchtlinge aufzunehmen das haben sie ja
gerade auch schon gesagt die fdp fordert
an europaweiten verteilungsschlüssel
heißt das dass man länder die da nicht
mitspielen auch sanktioniert wie zum
beispiel ungarn was gerade genannt wurde
dh dass man sie entweder an anderer
stelle in die pflicht nimmt also zum
beispiel mehr beitrag zur gemeinsamen
grenzsicherung mit verlaub demirel das
heißt ja nicht dass man da jetzt
schotten dicht macht aber ich glaube wir
haben einen anspruch darauf auch zu
kontrollieren wer bei uns sich aufhält
wir haben viele probleme auch gerade mit
mit kriminalität mit irgendwelchen
banden wo wir nicht wissen wo menschen
sind und das sind eben gerade nicht die
die geschützt werden wollen sondern die
diese systeme aus nutzen also von daher
glaube ich wir brauchen eine konz
kontrolle um dass er entsprechend auch
was ein bisschen und nach überzeugender
können so stellen deswegen kann man also
ganz legal ihre damit mehr dort mit in
anspruch nehmen oder durch entsprechende
zahlungen von denen die über ihre
anteile aufnehmen also von daher gibt es
möglichkeiten darauf einzugehen
wichtig ist doch jetzt dass wir aus
dieser sackgasse herauskommen dass wir
gerade auch bei den mitgliedstaaten
dafür werden einen gemeinsam auf unserer
werte auf unserem wertefundament
basierende lösungen zu finden
wir haben das alle in unseren
verfassungen wenn es um flüchtlinge oder
um asyl geht aber wir brauchen jetzt
eben auch eine lösung für die die
perspektiven suchen bin sehr dafür mehr
perspektiven auch in den heimatländern
zu schaffen aber mit verlaub das wird
zeit in anspruch nehmen da werden die
auch in der außenpolitik in der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit stärker
europäisch endlich auftreten müssen weil
dann blockieren wir uns zum teil auch
selber und deswegen müssen wir parallel
daran denken wie wir auch perspektiven
zu bieten dass integration nachher auch
erfolgreich möglich ist wir haben
zweifel darf noch sei ja darf ich dazu
auch noch eigentlich komme gleich zu
inhalten wir haben jede menge fragen
bekommen über facebook twitter und die
heute.de möglichst viele davon wollen
wir jedem von ihnen jetzt präsentieren
im kreuzverhör knackiger und kurze
antworten desto mehr themen kommen ins
spiel und in die sendung eine minute
zeit den anfang macht jörg merten und
die uhr läuft jetzt
was sagen sie menschen die nicht wählen
wollen
dass sie einen fehler beging ein
vereinter kontinent ist der nächste
logische schritt sind sie im 19ten oder
zwanzigsten jahrhundert hängen geblieben
nein das ist ein irrtum zu glauben dass
wir mit den vereinigten staaten von
europa die probleme der menschen besser
lösen können bräuchte europa nicht eine
einheitliche gemeinsame sprache ganz
sicherlich nicht wir leben von der
vielfalt unserer kulturen unserer
sprache das wollen wir erhalten weil
event wird cannabis überall in europa
legalisiert keine ahnung aber ich bin
kein freund davon brauchen wir die eu
weil viele probleme als nationalstaat
allein nicht mehr zu lösen sind
es gibt probleme die wir besser
gemeinsam lösen wenn sich die eu darauf
beschränkte wäre sie eine gute eu dann
wäre sie richtig sie macht leider die
falschen dinge könnte deutschland
alleine ohne die eu im rücken einen
handelskrieg gegen die usa bestehen es
ist klüger ist gemeinsam zu tun deswegen
haben den europäischen binnenmarkt und
es ist richtig und gut dass wir den
haben eine minimale überziehung vielen
dank für das erste kreuzverhör das
nächste folgt gleich mit frau demirel
und auch da gelten die gleichen regeln
eine minute ich frage im stakkato und
die uhr läuft jetzt es gibt ein
eu-förderprogramm in spanien zur
umschulung von arbeitslosen akademikern
zu pfeffern
ist das nicht verrückt es ist verrückt
aber wir sollten ja vor allen dingen
darum dafür kämpfen dass es mehr
arbeitsplätze gibt auch gerade in den
ländern des südens der moment negativ
von der troika politik betroffenen bei
der eu fällt einem unserer fragesteller
1 bei geld hört die freundschaft auf für
mich nicht weil ich kämpfe für eine welt
in der nicht das geld alles bestimmt
sondern die menschen und solidarität und
freundschaft der mittelgrund mittelpunkt
steht warum kann der grenzschutz europas
nicht sofort umgesetzt werden
ich finde es falsch mit grenzschutz zu
denken davon sicherheit schafft oder
dass man probleme löst und müssen
wirklich fundamentale lösung finden und
warum gibt es nicht in jedem
europäischen land eine volksabstimmung
zur flüchtlingsaufnahme ich finde wir
sollten tatsächlich die direkte
demokratie stärken
wir brauchen aber jetzt nicht
volksabstimmung zur flüchtlingsaufnahme
wie wäre es die usa wieder zum partner
europas zu machen
naja die usa ist schon lange partner der
europäischen union
vielen dank für diese erste rose
selbstverständlich werden frau bär und
frau keller auch die gelegenheit haben
etwas später in der sendung ins
kreuzverhör zu gehen wir kommen jetzt
zum thema geben sie mir denn vielleicht
noch die gelegenheit auf einen irrtum
von frau keller hinzuweisen die sache
nämlich alle hätten mit ihr gestimmt sie
machen faktencheck sollte man mal gucken
sagt an alle haushalte außer der csu
hätten mit bestimmt ist natürlich unfug
der ganze block rechts cvp hat er
natürlich nicht mitgestimmt und da
schlägt sie mal gelernt weil wir so
sieht das so gesammelte linken sie sagt
übrigens die abschaffung der demokratie
können sie auch mal überprüfen wir da
ganz interessant mehr kleben sie das
parlament abschaffen wollen dann
schaffen sie haben bekommen zum thema
populismus es geht um parteien von links
und rechtsaußen und viele feiern in
vielen ländern europas gerade erfolge
hat die eu nur politik für die eliten
gemacht hat brüssel versäumt die
globalisierungs verlierer anzusprechen
offene frage in die runde
ja also ich finde tatsächlich dass der
europäische binnenmarkt missbraucht
wurde für lohndumping und steuerdumping
ich will zum beispiel bringen wenn apple
im jahre 2014 auf eine million euro
gewinnen lediglich 50 euro steuern
gezahlt hat dann zeigt es bei vielen
menschen verständlicherweise dass man
berechtigterweise auch kritik am system
hat weil jeder bäckermeister jeder
normal abhängige zeit mehr steuern und
deshalb brauchen wir jetzt endlich auch
gerechte besteuerung von unternehmen und
konzernen auf europäischer ebene dafür
wollen wir werben steuerpolitik hatte
damit jetzt weniger was zu tun
grundsätzlich ist der binnenmarkt eine
errungenschaft erschafft eine win win
situation für alle beteiligten
weil der freie handel schafft und weil
dadurch staaten kooperative
kostenvorteile nutzen können das heißt
alle haben etwas davon dass eine der
wenigen wirklichen errungenschaften
europäischen union ist der binnenmarkt
überall wo nutzen ist gibt es auch
diese kosten die sind aber
vernachlässigenswert im vergleich zu dem
was der binnenmarkt und politik aus
brüssel nur für eliten frau wir das
größte problem was menschen sehen ist
dass politik aus brüssel häufig gar
nicht liefert das viele diskussionen
viel zu lange dauern wir haben gerade
schon eben über gemeinsame
migrationspolitik gesprochen dass wir
auch zum beispiel beim klima und
umweltschutz nicht schnell genug
vorankommen dass wir in fragen der
wettbewerbsfähigkeit nicht genau dort
investieren wo wir strukturwandel
begleiten müssen damit arbeitslose
arbeitslosigkeit abgebaut werden kann
oder gar nicht weiter entsteht wo wir
zukunftsfähige branchen aufstellen damit
zukunftsfähige arbeit auch gut bezahlte
arbeit da sein kann oder wo wir uns
entsprechend unserer werte gemeinsam
stärker als eine starke stimme für
menschenrechte für frieden für abrüstung
in der außenpolitik aufstellen ich find
das beschämend dass wir bei venezuela
immer noch keine europäische stimme an
dieser stelle haben jetzt droht in
nahost ein neuer krieg wir sind als
europäerinnen und europäer immer noch
nicht am start um hier entsprechend
unserer werte dort zu schauen wie wir
frieden schaffen können da wäre es
dringend notwendig zum beispiel als
europäer eine neue konferenz für
sicherheit zusammenarbeit in nahost
anzustreben damit die vielfältige
problemlage da auch gelöst werden kann
das ist im übrigen auch eine frage von
flucht ursachenbekämpfung weil das was
wir dort sehen das ist vielfach eben
auslöser dafür dass leute sich gezwungen
sehen ihre heimat zu verlassen ich würde
gerne noch einmal zurückschauen auf den
kern meiner frage ist und frau keller
fragen hat brüssel zu viele leute hinten
runterfallen lassen die sich jetzt gegen
die eu wenden
ich glaube schon dass wir uns gedanken
machen müssen wo kommt der populismus
her das hat viele verschiedene ursachen
und nicht alles was mit europa zu tun
aber ich will schon überlegen was können
wir dann auf der europäischen ebene tun
und was ist auch falsch gelaufen und da
denkt zum beispiel an die finanzkrise
ich glaube das war so ein punkt wo klar
ist das hat auch was mit uns zu tun weil
wenn wir eine europäische finanzkrise
haben wo ganz automatisch banken
gerettet werden wo milliarden
organisiert werden mal eben schnell um
banken zu retten aber gleichzeitig dann
austerität also kaputt sparprogramme
aufgefahren werden
wo eine troika die ja irgendwie aussieht
wie europa auch wenn das ja gar nichts
mit dem europäischen parlaments zu tun
hat aber sieht so aus wie europa
denn dafür sorgt dass in griechenland
die kleinen renten gekürzt werden dass
es keine dass menschen entlassen werden
also das hat schon
ich glaube schon dann müssen wir uns
gedanken machen warum es so weit kommen
konnte und wie wir dahin kommen dass so
etwas nie wieder passiert und was wir
jetzt tun können um den sozialen
schieflagen zu begegnen wir brauchen
sozialen zusammenhalt in europäischen
und nun das müssen wir stärker auf die
tagesordnung geben weil wir sind nicht
nur ein binnenmarkt wir sind europäer
und europäer und wir haben viele soziale
belange und an denen müssen wir arbeiten
wir sind schon mitten im thema
es geht um populismus und um eine
drohende spaltung der eu
dazu ein kurzer ein spielfilm
[Musik]
europa kritische parteien sind in vielen
ländern auf dem vormarsch in österreich
italien ungarn und polen sind sie sogar
an der regierung beteiligt und auch bei
der europawahl könnten populisten und
eu-gegner die großen gewinner seien
während christ und sozialdemokraten um
ihre mehrheit bangen müssen wird den eu
kritikern bis zu ein drittel der sitze
vorhergesagt nachdem die eu-skeptiker
bislang auf drei fraktionen zersplittert
waren
träumen sie für die zukunft von neuen
allianzen unter anderem planen die
italienische lega der französische
wasser limo national die deutsche fd und
die österreichische fpö den
schulterschluss inhaltliche
übereinstimmung gibt es neben der
eu-kritik zwar nur wenig trotzdem
könnten die abgeordneten wichtige
entscheidungen zum beispiel zum
klimawandel oder zur asylpolitik mit
einer art blockade taktik künstlich
verzögert reformen würden noch
schwieriger als bisher
der frust der wähler würde weiter
wachsen und profitieren könnten davon
wieder einmal die populisten
[Musik]
der linke und rechte populismus zählt zu
den hauptproblemen der eu sagt die afd
die fdp entschuldigung was wollen sie
denn konkret dagegen tun
zunächst einmal vor allem verhindern
dass am 26
diese prognosen die ja noch keine
wahlergebnisse sind auch wirklich sich
bewahrheiten
ich glaube dass man menschen noch
überzeugen kann mit klaren konzepten und
vor allem auch zu zeigen dass man den
mut hat solche modernisierungskonzept
für die europäische union umzusetzen
nicht nur zu reden bis tief in die nacht
familienfoto und nachher nicht zu
liefern sondern wirklich etwas
umzusetzen was den menschen vor ort in
ihren heimatorten etwas bringt klar zu
machen dass wir gemeinsam erfolgreich
sein können wenn wir uns zum beispiel an
die spitze setzen bei neuen technologien
bei forschung und entwicklung wenn wir
mehr gemeinsam in bildung investieren
wenn wir dafür sorgen dass die menschen
sich begegnen sich wieder austauschen
das ist zum beispiel an recht gibt sechs
monate nicht nur als studierender
sondern als berufsschüler sich in einem
anderen land ausbilden zu lassen sich
gegenseitig kennenzulernen weil wer sich
kennt der versteht sich dann auch und
deswegen wirklich nach vorne zu blicken
zu zeigen wir können diese europäische
union wieder fit machen für die zukunft
für die zukunft der menschen in diesen
vielen verschiedenen ländern kulturen
und nationen
das kann meines erachtens populismus
schon bei der wahl klein halten und
ansonsten werden wir schlicht mehr
nächsten legislaturperiode mit einer
mehrheit für so eine modernisierungs
agenda für mich am liebsten mit frau
westergaards kommissionspräsidentin
zeigen dass es möglich ist die eu wieder
anders aufzustellen
jetzt haben wir sie
sie haben in diesen kleinen ein studio
film gesehen den gesellschaft von herz
wie nie und anderen streben sie da so
eine art internationalen nationalen
nationalisten an nein wir sind keine
nationalisten
das halte ich für falsch genauso wie ich
den begriff des populismus wir werden
wie immer assoziiert für mich selbst
sogar die frau keller eine vertreterin
der öko populisten ja das ist populismus
so einfach was sie machen zu dem thema
konvergenz sicherlich noch was wir
anstreben in der tat und wir stehen dass
ich nur an sein und wir werden das tun
das kann ich hier verbindlich sagen ist
eine eine große gemeinsame fraktion zu
bilden
in der die genannten tatsächlich sein
werden wir werden als alternative für
deutschland zusammen gehen mit unseren
italienischen freunden von der leger mit
den österreicher von der fpö mit dem
raster national und etlichen anderen das
ist im moment schon eine gruppe die
fraktionsstärke hat und die wird nach
dem wahltag noch richtig anwachsen und
wir werden dann die tal die interessen
für ein europa des gesunden
menschenverstandes vertreten genau das
das soziale europa de das heißt das
heißt zu teilen auch da wo die weiteren
unfug machen blockade natürlich werden
wir nein votieren wo unsinn gemacht wird
und da dort sehr viel unsinn gemacht
wird wird nein relativ häufig die folge
sein
ich sage aber auch wir sind pragmatiker
wir agieren nicht ideologisch wo
vernünftige vorschläge sind die können
kommen von wo immer sie wollen wenn es
vernünftig ist werden wir dem zustimmen
unser maßstab ist dient es den menschen
in der europäischen union ungeachtet der
frage aus welcher ecke das kommt dann
stimmen wir zu halten wir das so nicht
gegeben stimmen wir konsequent mit nein
im europawahlprogramm der linke ist zum
teil sehr massive kritik an der eu zu
finden
tragen sie damit nicht selbst zum euro
verdruss bei nein im gegenteil also wir
kämpfen ja für eine gerechtigkeit wende
für eine sozial ökologische wende und
für abrüstung in der europäischen union
bekämpfende konkrete forderung und
verbesserung ich finde dass wir nicht in
einen wahlkampf gehen sollten als eine
partei mit abstrakten bekenntnissen für
oder gegen europa unsere aufgabe als
politik ist es konkret zu formulieren
was wir gut finden was wir ändern wollen
und wie wir das ändern wollen und das
leisten wir mit unserem programm
wir nehmen uns auch die freiheit da die
kritik anzubringen wo sie berechtigt ist
und es gibt ja diese
themenfelder aber wenn ich kurz darf
auch wegen dieser frage rechtspopulismus
und wie man dagegen vorgehen kann und
sollte ich will jetzt gar nicht unser
programm hier an dieser stelle benennen
ich will nur darauf hinweisen dass am 19
mai jetzt kommenden sonntag tatsächlich
in vielen städten in deutschland viele
menschen auf die straße gehen wollen um
nationalismus und rechte hetze einhalt
zu gebieten um ein zeichen dagegen zu
setzen
und ich finde genau dass der kampf gegen
rechte hetze gegen den nationalismus
auch ein kampf ist denn die
zivilgesellschaft gemeinsam führen muss
die man durchaus auch parteiübergreifend
für muss auch gemeinsam darstellen auch
gewollt sondern und wo man auch kirchen
gewerkschaft mit verschiedenen jobs
zusammen gehen muss und deshalb meine
bitte
unabhängig davon in welcher politischen
partei man sich nah fühlt lassen sie uns
am 19
bitte ein klares zeichen setzen denn der
nationalismus die rechte hetze die
steigt die ist gefährlich gerade wir in
europa wissen ja auch was es zu was ist
führen kann
denn solche rechte hetzer und rassisten
wirklich immer stärker werden wir kennen
die geschichten wenn man so alles gibt
wenn man über populismus
dann muss man schon auch nach
großbritannien gucken
der brh exit prozess ist ein quälender
er ist immer noch nicht abgeschlossen
die briten werden auch mit abstimmen und
die eu gegner liegen in den umfragen
deutlich vorn frau bär ist das nicht
gleich eine ziemliche bürde für das neue
parlament also insgesamt ist das
wirklich ein albtraum wenn ein so
wichtiges mitglied denn überhaupt ein
mitglied aus der europäischen union raus
will ich hätte mir gewünscht dass das
damals schon als dieses referendum sich
dann gezeigt hat dass damals das schon
ein weckruf gewesen wäre für die
europäische union auch mal über die
eigene verfassung nachzudenken
jetzt werden wir im europäischen
parlament mit einer durchaus schwierigen
situationen umgehen müssen dass
abgeordnete die zum teil werden ja nicht
alle seien die liberaldemokraten kämpfen
in großbritannien immer noch für den
verbleib in der europäischen union von
großbritannien
dass wir aber mit einer ganzen reihe von
abgeordneten umgehen müssen die zum
beispiel über die weiteren finanzplanung
die über den kommissionspräsidenten die
über die besetzung auch der
verschiedenen ausschüsse in im
europäischen parlament mitbestimmen und
das ist natürlich schon eine bürde da
wird man schauen müssen dass da keine
blockaden stattfinden
wir werden einfach dafür doch noch
einmal im gespräch zu sein und zu
schauen ob wir und wie wir möglichst
enge beziehungen auch nach einem
eventuellen braig cit mit großbritannien
schaffen können
ich glaube das ist für uns alle wichtig
das hat nicht nur fragen des handels das
sind auch weitere fragen des austauschs
in wissenschaft in forschung und
entwicklung und großbritannien war immer
auch ein verlässlicher partner wenn es
um innere und äußere sicherheit ging
also von daher wird großbritannien
auch wenn es nicht mehr mitglied der eu
ist hoffentlich weiter ein sehr sehr
wichtiges mitglied europas bleiben und
bin auf jeden fall dafür gestand heute
will großbritannien austreten und die
afg schließt zumindest mal nicht aus
dass auch deutschland austreten könnte
dann nämlich wenn es mit den reformen
die sie fordern nicht funktioniert oder
nicht in angemessener zeit in kurzer
form welche reformen und was ist
angemessene zeit erneuten wir wollen die
ganze entwicklung mehr weiteren
vergemeinschaftung hin zu den
vereinigten staaten von europa hin zu
einer eigenstaatlichkeit der union
stoppen und ich bin überzeugt davon dass
uns das gelingt weil wir haben
verbündete wie das auch nicht wollen
diese bewegung wird stärker werden und
wir werden die mehrheit dafür generieren
dass ein austritt nicht nötig wird der
ist für uns so steht das auch in unserem
wahlprogramm die ultima ratio
wir wollen das nicht sagen wir
ausdrücklich sagen andere über uns
anders weil wir die errungenschaften der
union durchaus sehen aber dieser fatalen
irrweg der immer weiteren
vergemeinschaftung der muss enden
und wenn der nicht beendet werden kann
dann wäre die letzte aller möglichkeiten
wird die europäische union e
zusammenbrechen dass man austritt das
wird dann aber nicht nur deutschland
betreffen sondern andere staaten auch
ich sage noch mal in aller deutlichkeit
unser ziel ist das nicht trocken
würden sie das nachvollziehen kann es
nicht nachvollziehen die europäische
union ist sicherlich nicht ohne fehler
aber es ist trotzdem die beste idee die
wir hier auf diesem kontinent hatten
und wenn wir uns mal anschauen können
[Musik]
wenn wir uns anschauen was wir erreicht
haben auf diesem kontinent was unsere
vorväter und vor mütter hier erreicht
haben auf diesem kontinent ihn gemeinsam
wieder aufzubauen nach so viel krieg
nach so viel zerstörung dann ist das
eine leistung das kann man gar nicht
genug wertschätzen und alle fragen alle
großen herausforderung unserer zeit die
können wir nur auf europäischer ebene
angehen weil wir nur an klima an die
klimakrise denken hat umweltzerstörung
das klima macht ja nicht an der grenze
halt die umweltzerstörung macht sich an
der grenze halt wir brauchen die
europäische union darf sie natürlich
auch in anderen fragen und sie müssen
uns aber überlegen wie können wir sie
noch besser machen wie können wir sie
noch weiter ausbauen wir diskutieren zum
beispiel gerade die idee einer föderalen
republik weil wir wollen dass alle
europäerinnen und europäer sind eine
föderale struktur haben ja wohl das
wollen wir da stehen wo keiner weise
gerade so schön in fahrt
wir kommen zum kreuzverhör zweiter teil
mittel fragen aus dem netz und den
antworten in knackiger kürze eine minute
zeit für möglichst viele fragen ska
keller beginnt die uhr läuft
wofür steht die abkürzung star franziska
aber geheimnis ein zuschauer wirft ihnen
vor die komplette dritte welt nach
deutschland importieren zu wollen was
sagen sie dazu
wann ist endlich schluss mit der
unsäglichen null zinspolitik der ezb die
meine ersparnisse frist die ezb hat in
der tat etwas geleistet was wir
insgesamt in europäischen union hätten
leisten sollen nämlich den euro zu
retten ich glaube da können wir noch
eine weile dankbar dafür sein zeigt
dicht viktor orban das auch ein
nationalstaat das problem migration
regeln kann
indem man seine abstellt und
menschenrechte missachtet auch die
pressefreiheit einschränken ich glaube
nein
wie wollen sie mehr abgelehnte und
kriminell asylbewerber möglichst schnell
abschließen
wir wollen ein faires asylverfahren ein
asylverfahren kann natürlich auch so
ausgehen dass am ende steht
nein aber wir sind nicht stolz auf
abschiebungen und auch die müssen kann
man verfolgen abfolgen werden alle
menschen haben menschenrechte
vielen dank fast eine punktlandung
einmal kurz atem holen und dann geht es
gleich weiter mit nicola beer die minute
läuft jetzt runter ich bin
gebäudereiniger wie soll ich im alter
von meiner mini rente leben schreibt
jemand deswegen müssen wir dringend
dafür sorgen dass wir andere stelle
sicherungsmöglichkeiten haben dass wir
auch entsprechend gute löhne haben und
deswegen setzen wir gemeinsam auf
investitionen wettbewerbsrecht ist es
nicht ein fehler die briten trotz der
exit wählen zu lassen
nein das schreiben jetzt einfach die
rechtslage so vor sie haben das recht
weil sie nach wie vor mitglied der
europäischen union sind aber es wird
sicherlich ein referendum über auch die
verhandlungen großbritanniens über den
dreck zieht die gelb westen in
frankreich und ihre forderungen wie
stehen sie dazu
wir müssen aufpassen dass wir unsere
gesellschaften nicht spalten indem wir
zum beispiel beim thema klima und
umweltschutz nur die kleinen und
mittleren einkommen belasten ich möchte
gern in dem fall europäische strategien
neue technologien so einsetzen dass alle
sich klima und umweltschutz leisten
können in deutschland besitzen 5 und 40
milliardären so viel vermögen wie die
hälfte der bevölkerung wie kann eine
kluge steuer und sozialpolitik das
ändern darf ich noch einfach noch besser
frage indem wir wettbewerbsfähigkeit
stärken gute arbeitsplätze schaffen aber
insbesondere auch kleine und mittlere
einkommen von steuern und sozialabgaben
entlasten
[Applaus]
wir kommen zum letzten thema
wirtschafts- und umweltpolitik auch hier
eine kurze filmische einführung
[Musik]
europas konjunktur aussichten sind trübe
vor allem italien gilt als tickende
zeitbombe und auch in europas größter
volkswirtschaft deutschland fürchten
manche eine rezession
sorgen macht aber auch die immer noch
hohe jugendarbeitslosigkeit vor allem in
griechenland italien und spanien und die
digitalisierung hier verliert der
kontinent zunehmend den anschluss und
auch die umweltpolitik verlangt nach
gemeinsamen konzepten zu klimaschutz
mobilität agrarpolitik und artenvielfalt
doch während die konkurrenz aus den usa
und china immer stärker auf
protektionismus und nationalismus setzt
streitet europa über die richtige
antwort
der französische präsident mal kommt zum
beispiel fordert ein eigenes budget für
die eurozone
außerdem einen einheitlichen
europäischen mindestlohn
die bundesregierung dagegen hält weiter
fest an der idee der freien märkte
eine vergemeinschaftung von schulden und
die europäisierung der sozialsysteme
soll es nicht geben
klar ist aber schon jetzt ohne eine
gemeinsame wirtschaftliche linie ist
europas zukunft in gefahr
[Musik]
europa steht vor schwierigen
wirtschaftlichen zeiten das ist die
quintessenz dieses films erneuten was
wir die afd denn tun um die wirtschaft
zu stärken
wir wollen eine vernünftige
steuerpolitik das ist extrem wichtig wir
wollen das heißt vernünftig eine
vernünftige steuerpolitik heißt die
enorm hohe steuerlast die wir derzeit in
deutschland haben zu reduzieren damit
steuer und abgabenlast dass die
zweithöchste der welt also ich nehme
jetzt bezug auf die oecd können sie
nachschauen
checken sie und das hat aber auch noch
keiner dritten hatte ich nur
sicherheitshalber weil bei uns für das
gerne in frankreich aber was da stecken
wir müssen wir müssen sehen dass wir
vernünftige ordnungspolitische
rahmenbedingungen haben und das heißt
wir sind eine partei die boost komplett
auf dem fundament der sozialen
marktwirtschaft so wie wir sie hatten
das ist ein erfolgsmodell das haben wir
schritt für schritt verlassen und dahin
müssen wir zurückkehren mit einem
vernünftigen ordnungsrahmen einer hohen
staatlichen abstinenz die der staat gibt
den ordnungsrahmen vor zum beispiel das
wettbewerbsrecht zum beispiel als
steuerrecht und auf der basis können wir
wirtschaftlich erfolgreich arbeiten
frage an die linke was ist ihr
wirtschaftspolitischer kurs wohin soll
europa steuern
wir wollen vor allen dingen
investitionen fördern auch in eine
soziale infrastruktur davon profitiert
auf den mittelstand muss man dazu sagen
weil wir wollen auch vor allen dingen
den mittelstand und untere einkommen
entlasten indem wir endlich
steuergerechtigkeit herstellen wir haben
eine situation wie sie eben schon gesagt
haben dass die superreichen konzern
immer reicher geworden sind und der
mittelstand die hauptlast trägt und die
arme und quasi die last tragen durch
sozialkürzungen damit muss schluss sein
und wenn man das ernst machen möchte und
gute bildung gute gesundheit eine gute
infrastruktur für alle menschen
gewährleisten möchte dann muss man sagen
ja jetzt bitten wir mal die wiesn
konzerne zu kaffee oder die super
reichen und vermögenden zu kasse und
hier war in den vergangenen jahren
tatsächlich eine politik der schieflage
das wollen wir ändern und wir wollen
eine sozialunion schaffen wir wollen ein
europa der menschen schaffen indem eben
jeder gut und zukunftsfähig leben kann
gerecht leben kann das gleiche wollen
mindestlöhne und wir wollen eine bremse
für prekäre beschäftigung das heißt wenn
befristete beschäftigung leiharbeit all
diese dinge schlecht
unfaire arbeitsbedingungen überhand
gewinnen da müssen mitgliedsstaaten
endlich agieren wir können ja die
situation in deutschland schon sehen
dass hier auch immer mehr menschen unter
diesen schlechten arbeitsbedingungen
leiden ich als gewerkschafterin kennen
mich dann natürlich aus und ich sage
damit möchte ich brechen ich möchte dass
die menschen gemeinsam miteinander die
freiheiten in europa leben können dafür
brauchen sie soziale absicherungen nun
ist europa im großen ganzen ein gut
funktionierender wirtschaftsraum das hat
man nach der finanzkrise gesehen
das sieht man an der arbeitslosenquote
die wir gerade haben von 6,5 unter den
28 noch eu-staaten auch wenn wie im film
gesehen in bestimmten regionen
südeuropas italien griechenland spanien
das unheimlich hohe
jugendarbeitslosigkeit gibt aber die
leute haben schon das gefühl dass
soziale kommt dabei zu kurz frau bär
wie kann man da nach steuern indem man
etwas gegen arbeitslosigkeit gerade in
den regionen die sie genannt haben wir
ihn nutzen heute die europäischen
geldern noch viel zu sehr um diese
strukturen zu konservieren oder die
symptome abzufedern ich möchte diese
arbeitslosigkeit bekämpfen und es geht
nur indem wir strukturwandel begleiten
indem wir anschieben dass dort eben auch
in anderen in neuen branchen vielleicht
nicht gerade nur bei den schäfern
entsprechend zukunftsträchtige
arbeitsplätze entstehen und das bedeutet
für mich dass wir den mittelstand
stärken müssen wenn wir momentan eine
diskussion wo künstlich mit staatlichen
geldern große geschaffen werden soll
nein wir haben in unserem mittelstand
quer durch europa die meisten arbeits
die meisten ausbildungsplätze
da sind auch unsere weltmarktführer für
viele viele technologien waren und
dienstleistungen da müssen wir darauf
setzen das heißt alles was den kleinen
belastet was für den handwerker den
gewerbetreibende das familienunternehmen
nicht funktioniert das muss weg das darf
nicht ein weg eingang in regulierung auf
europäischer ebene bieten weil da
entsteht heimat da entsteht arbeit zu
hause da kann ich heimatliche wurzeln
haben und trotzdem den europäischen
freiraum auf dem gesamten kontinent
nutzen wir haben es gesagt
vieles läuft im prinzip
wirtschaftspolitisch gut und erfreulich
wenn man es auch mit anderen regionen
dieser welt vergleicht was würden sie
sagen frau keller für die grünen ist das
erfolgsrezept um dann noch besser zu
werden
ich glaube wir haben schon großes
problem die jugendarbeitslosigkeit ist
ja das eklatanteste beispiel davon wenn
wir die jugendarbeitslosigkeit in
griechenland von 39 prozent ist das
nicht normal
und dann ist es nicht okay das ist ein
problem das uns alle angeht weil der
binnenmarkt hat schon zu sehr
unterschiedlichen fortschritten geführt
in verschiedenen ländern wir müssen
endlich zum einen kommt dass auch
soziale ziele in der europäischen union
verbindlich werden aber wir müssen
wirtschaft auch wirklich neu denken für
uns steht der mensch im mittelpunkt und
auch die wirtschaft muss sich auf den
menschen ausrichten und zwar auf den
menschen innerhalb seiner umwelt
demzufolge muss auch umwelt da eine
rolle spielen aber das ist ja auch
relativ positiv wird zusammen denken
weil gerade jetzt wer auch immer in die
klimafreundlichen technologien
investiert da produziert ist produzierte
erforscht da entstehen doch die
arbeitsplätze der zukunft die auch nicht
auslaufen sondern längerfristig hier
sind aber gerade sehen wir eigentlich
nur zu wie die klimafreundlichen
technologien sonst von der welt
erschaffen werden nur nicht hier und da
brauchen wir endlich eine europäische
industrie strategie die auch dazu führt
dass wir hier die technologien dass wir
hier die produkte haben die erstens
unsere wirtschaft auf ist statisch
deutschland als auch dafür sorgen dass
die arbeitsplätze der zukunft hier sind
natürlich dankbar wenn wir sagen
technologieoffen dran gehen würden das
europäische parlament hat jetzt zum
beispiel verhindert dass alternative
kraftstoffe für verbrennungsmotoren für
den flotten mix der automobilbranche
anerkannt wird das wird hier massiv
arbeitsplätze kosten obwohl es genau so
umweltschonend ob es wohl es genauso
nachhaltig ist also dann bitte
technologieoffene wege wie wir diesen
klima und umweltschutz für den ich sehr
bin wo ich sogar gerne noch engagierte
ziele hätten wir den erreichen
wir sollten als politik die ziele setzen
aber wir sollten nachher sehen dass wir
die beste technologie denen überlassen
die da eben entwickeln und forschen und
nicht politisch sagen es ist dann nur
das batteriewerk offen beim namen die
machen die die arbeitsplätze
thematisch kaputt wenn sich das schon
das kommt aus dem haus in dem ich
arbeite das ist zum zum schämen
da werden grenzwerte beschlossen die
unsere komplette automobilindustrie
kaputtmachen zugunsten einer technologie
die nicht ausgereift ist und die wird
verlaub die objektive studien belegen
überhaupt nicht weniger emissionen
bringt das heißt diese sogenannte
klimapolitik und klima ist der rede die
grünen da veranstalten die führt hier zu
massiven einbrüchen wir sind eine
industrie nation
wir machen uns auf diese art und weise
die zukunft kaputt und da sind die die
das tun und die behaupten irrigerweise
noch weil sie einfach von wirtschafts
nichts verstehen
sie würden auch noch arbeitsplätze
schaffen es ist absurd was da geschehen
das ist aller deutlichkeit zu sagen das
ist ab jetzt sind wir an schönen
reizklima gelandet in deutschland dem
auto und da möchte ich vor frau keller
die gerade auch angesprochen worden ist
ähnliches spiel wieder bringen sie
wollen ja bis 2030 das ende von diesel
und benziner
wenn man sich jetzt mal anguckt wie die
neuzulassungen in diesem quartal in
europa aussehen das sind gerade mal zwei
prozent e autos das klingt ein bisschen
nach einer utopie aber nur aber ich bin
ja angegriffen worden da würde ich auch
gerne was zu sagen
sie produzieren wie sie produzieren wir
aber aber frau bär ich finde es
technologien definitiv unterschätzt
haben sie aber noch zum januar dieses
jahres gesagt dass sie sich noch nicht
so ganz sicher sind mit dem klimawandel
wenn es stimmt auch wieder mal sehr erst
in das werden sie ihr einen geld
geändert haben
wir sind da sehr froh wenn die auch die
liberalen in zukunft mehr als bisher
sich für klimaschutz im europäischen
parlament einsetzen wenn sie jetzt die
abstimmungen in der vergangenen
legislatur haben auch endlos nachgeguckt
dann sind sie dann noch nicht so der
klimaforscher haben kann sich ja noch
ändern zu den autos zu den autoren sagen
das machen würden dass man denkt ja
niemand schutz daher gerne kommen und
nicht nur symbolpolitik die leute
belastbar zu den autos wir haben die
situation dass deutsche
automobilhersteller immer nur noch
fossile verbrennungsmotoren herstellen
obwohl china angekündigt hat dass sie
keine fossilen verbrennungsmotoren zu
mehr zulassen werden in den harz angehen
können nicht so viele europäische länder
sun gehört
ich frag mich wohin wollen sie denn ihre
autos verkaufen die müssen doch jetzt
die e autos investieren damit es noch
ein absatzmarkt für deutsche autos und
was macht vw stattdessen die sagen wir
machen nur die aller tollsten größten
teuersten autos die werden
elektrifiziert dabei bräuchten wir doch
jetzt ein europäisches auto für den
normalverbraucher das elektrisch fährt
und auch noch ein paar ladestation
wir haben die skepsis sei kein pendant
wir haben die skepsis von herrn
klimaschutzpolitik vorhin schon gehört
die eifel gesagt das ist ein irrweg sie
wollen zurück zur kohle und atomstrom
sind in den umwelt und zukunft wurscht
also lassen sie mich sagen ich bin vater
von fünf kindern ich habe enkel
ich habe eine sehr hohe
zukunftskonferenz weil ich möchte dass
die hier in europa in unserer heimat in
zukunft gut leben können dazu ist klima
hysterie mit verlaub nicht nicht die
nicht was wir brauchen ist ein star an
oder gerade bei ökonomischer und
ökologischer realismus und dazu gehört
eine vernünftige energiepolitik der
klimapolitik ist im kern letztlich
umwelt und energiepolitik und wenn wir
feststellen dass 81 prozent der
weltweiten das weltweite
energieverbrauchs auf der basis öl kohle
gas basiert 81 prozent dass weitere fünf
prozent auf kernenergie basierende
bleibt 14 prozent für andere energien
übrig und wenn sie hier in europa
wohlgemerkt wir deutschen haben 2,4
prozent des primärenergieverbrauchs der
welt wenn wir hier in europa jetzt ein
umstieg machen auf rein erneuerbare dann
wird das ökologisch das prophezeie ich
eben mit großer gewissheit und das
können sie anhand wirklich des
datenmaterials problemlos überprüfen
nichts bringen gar nichts bringen
wir werden aber hier einen gravierenden
ökonomischen niedergang erleben das kann
der weg nicht sein sondern wir brauchen
eine vernünftige schrittweise umstellung
im laufe des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhunderts dastehen vertritt steht
eine vertreterin einer partei die mit 2d
future und so weiter kinder und
jugendlichen erzählt wenn der nicht
binnen zwölf jahren aus der kohle raus
sind wohlgemerkt hier
da geht die welt unter mit verlaub das
ist großer kokolores wir brauchen hier
augenmaß und mitte und einen
vernünftigen energiemix dazu gehören
alle energieträger selbstverständlich
auch erneuerbare
und wenn niemand hat etwas gegen
windparks offshore vor der küste aber
wenn wir unsere landschaft systematisch
kaputt machen damit auch biodiversität
zerstören weil wir ganz extensiv mit den
windrädern in die fläche gehen dann
erweisen wir unserem land teilweise mit
dem naturschutz einen fürchterlichen
bärendienst irreversibel ist trotzdem
haben alle eine tatsache dass das thema
klima und umweltschutz immer wichtiger
wird im bewusstsein der mensch ist ist
ja auch ein wichtiger union ich würde
gerne die linke mal ansprechen in ihrem
wahlprogramm haben sie ein sehr langes
kapitel dazu soweit ich mich erinnere
war das jetzt nicht immer die
kernkompetenz ihrer partei haben sie
langsam angst dass sie den anschluss
verlieren die grünen lange zeit
landessprecherin die waren von anfang an
neben der und bei der hambacher bewegung
bei den menschen die den hambacher forst
retten wollten
auch leider zu einer zeit in dem spd und
grüne damals dort noch andere beschlüsse
gefasst haben insofern nein wir wollen
den sozialen und ökologischen wandeln
wir wollen es zusammen verbinden aber
erlauben sie mir vielleicht an herrn
leuten und auch frau bär bzw ihrem
vorsitzenden sie selber vielleicht nicht
unbedingt werden denn da noch mal den
hinweis zu geben
ich möchte mich bedanken bei den jungen
menschen die jeden freitag auf die
straße gehen und deutlich machen dass
sie für ihre zukunft kämpfen und im
moment wirklich einen gedanken wandel in
der gesellschaft und in der politik
beigetragen haben und es sind nicht
irgendwelche kinder es sind menschen die
für ihre zukunft für ihre politischen
inhalte auf die straße geht und das sind
diejenigen die die wissenschaft heute
mehr verstanden haben als scheinbar hier
der herr system
sie haben jetzt sehr viele beiträge
kommt dass er komplett vor dem er ihr
deshalb bekommt sie haben jetzt noch mal
das wort hat auch eine chance ja so
widersprechen in aller deutlichkeit ich
wende mich doch nicht gegen diese jungen
menschen wieder auf die straße gehen
die haben nur das ein problem das sie
gar nicht erkennen können sie werden
nämlich systematisch fehlinformiert und
das ist die problematik es wird nicht
sie werden sie werden gezielt vielen
jetzt in richtung in erneuerbare
energien jetzt mit einem kohleausstieg
und das ist auch richtig dass das unter
anderem jetzt es ist schlicht und
einfach so dass wir den ausstehenden
dieser fordern in der würde die zukunft
dieser jungen menschen selber zerstören
und das haus vor dem können übrigens
junge menschen und glauben sie mir ich
habe viel damit zu tun auch dadurch dass
viele jugendliche bei mir im haus sind
weil ich kinder habe sie erkennen das
sehr genau wieder die fehlinformation
ist aber der mainstream ist jetzt in
diese richtung und mit diesem menschen
müssen wir leben
wir müssen aufpassen dass wir da nicht
eine fundamentale entwicklung nehmen die
dann irgendwann nicht mehr korrigierbar
ist es ist mir durchaus bewusst dass das
eine minderheitsmeinung ist aber ich
kann sie faktenbasiert vertreten und das
problem ist dass hier statt auf fakten
basierten arbeiten rein emotional mit
glaubensbekenntnissen gearbeitet wie wir
alle müssen den klimawandel vorhin eine
wichtige frage gestellt ob wir das
überhaupt können soll es wird gesagt
wenn wir das nicht verhindern
dann ist hier energien in zwölf jahren
die lichter aus das wird nicht geschehen
ich will nur sagen wir haben sich der
wald ist nicht gestorben wird die
familie zu haben und recht das macht die
welt auch nicht weil sie haben in einer
anderen zdf-sendungen schon mal eine
teilschuld zahl genannt und einen
falschen bezug genommen wir haben das
geschäft in diesen fakten parat
unterricht heißt sie gesagt haben
ich habe da freilich habe damit ihre
hände vehement aber nicht auf uns
zugekommen ich habe das feedback nicht
einkommen sie haben gesagt zwei drittel
der studien zum klimaschutz sind sich
nicht sicher ob das irgendwie menschen
gemacht ist oder nicht das ist falsch
denn diese zwei drittel haben gar nicht
nach der ursache gefragt sondern ganz
andere dinge untersucht und dann hatten
sie wiederum recht die anderen zehn
prozent sind über 90 prozent der klaren
ansicht es ist mensch gemacht zu tragen
also das muss man schon klar ich glaube
ich auch mal klar sagen dass es diese
gewissheit auf wissenschaftlicher seite
schon gibt so und dem einmal kurz gar
keiner bitte dass wir im jahr 2019
darüber streiten ob sie klimawandel gibt
den produkten werde dafür streiten um
den klimawandel werden das in den
nächsten steht und auf einen mörder
teilnehmer wann wird die predigt die
frau dann wieder von unfug welchen
weniger schwer hat es ja wir wissen ja
was zu tun ist ist matschig darüber
streiten welches instrument jetzt zuerst
zum 22 aber wir müssen dringend handeln
die wissenschaft sagt uns dass es nur
noch ein begrenztes zeitfenster gibt da
gibt es dafür daran müssen wir dringend
etwas ändern und wir wollen verschiedene
instrumente wir müssen zum beispiel
endlich dafür sorgen dass die bahn
mindestens gleich gestellt wird mit den
fluglinien und das wirke rosin besteuern
und nicht dem mehrwert die bahn mehr
besteuern als airlines wir müssen dahin
kommen dass der co2 ausstoß einen preis
bekommt damit wir auch die anreize
schaffen gerade für unternehmen dass sie
sich klimafreundlich technologien
leisten können dass es sich lohnt und
das müssen wir zurückzahlen an die
menschen pro kopf damit wir einen
sozialen ausgleich schaffen wir müssen
für die kohleregion mitdenken und und
und es gibt viel zu tun aber müssen
daran gehen und wir können nicht länger
warten
darüber diskutieren wie wichtig dass
jetzt ist wegen eines gewinns
es zeigt uns sehr dass nicola der schon
seit einiger zeit versucht sofort
zukommt bitte nicht zu lang aber sie
haben das ganz fertig also ich bin ja
dafür dass wir dringend angehen und
nicht nur diskutieren aber dann lassen
sie uns bitte fehler aus der
vergangenheit nicht wiederholen
ja wir müssen co2 an fühlbaren
preisgeben aber über ein zertifikat
handelsmodell dass die emission noch
raus nimmt und nicht nur diejenigen
zahlen ist die dann weiter emittieren
dürfen die weiter verschmutzen dürfen
ich will dass diese verschmutzung
aufhört und das heißt diese
handelssysteme eben auch nicht nur für
große kraftwerke sondern das heißt auch
auf den verkehr auf die wärme auch die
fragen der landwirtschaft rüber zu gehen
es möglichst auch international
wenigstens europäisch jetzt schon
anzugehen und voranzuschreiten
der zweite punkt ist wir müssen zum
beispiel darauf setzen dass wir auch mit
europäischen geldern europäischen
technologie in anderen regionen dieses
erdballs investieren um dort schnellere
fortschritte zu machen als das was in
europa mit all dem was wir schon
geschafft haben noch möglich ist da
könnte die eu jetzt vorangehen wenn es
um die ziele 2030 geht weil bislang
konzentriert man sich nur auf europa wir
könnten aber mit demselben geld viel
schneller viel nachhaltiger viel mehr
erreichen wenn wir andere länder
unterstützen die noch nicht so weit sind
als bei uns die letzten fünf zentimeter
oben noch herausholen zu wollen
nachher ist es dem klima egal ob es in
deutschland gerettet wird oder sonst ist
es nämlich global und das heißt wir
müssen auch global denken an dieser
stelle auch als europäische und so jetzt
kommen hier schlussrunde weil die
sendung eigentlich schon vorbei ist aber
jeder von ihnen führen soll doch noch
mal die möglichkeit haben zu wort zu
kommen ich würde sie einfach fragen wenn
sie eine idee ein herzensprojekt für
europa hätten dass sie umsetzen konnten
was wäre das in 30 sekunden jürgen heute
direkte demokratie und bürgerliche
freiheiten das ist extrem wichtig
subsidiaritätsprinzip den staat von
unten denken die menschen in freiheit
leben lassen die freiheit durch strikte
rechtsstaatlichkeit sichern ich ganz
kurz am anders 30 sekunden das ist das
was wir tun müssen
die eu muss sich dazu ganz stark
zurücknehmen weil so viel zu viele dinge
tut die genau dagegen
das ist unser problem mit der
europäischen union heute das müssen wir
ändern daran arbeiten wir und das werden
wir im neuen europäischen parlament
erfolgreich tun und damit ist die zeit
genau vorbei und wir sind bei uns leben
demirel auch für sie 30 30 sekunden die
laufen jetzt ich kämpfe für ein europa
der menschen in denen ihre freiheiten
und ihre belange im mittelpunkt stehen
deshalb möchte ich eigentlich eine
sozialunion schaffen in dem menschen die
arbeit noch von ihrer arbeit leben
können eine bedingung dafür ist endlich
armutsfeste mindestlöhne zu schaffen in
deutschland werden zwölf euro in einem
anderen mitgliedstaat eine andere summe
aber in jedem land so dass es klar ist
dass jeder der arbeitet auch davon leben
kann oder ich möchte endlich damit
brechen dass wir prekäre arbeit haben
schlechter arbeitsbedingungen für
menschen haben ich möchte soziale und
ökologische standards vereinen kann
das herzliche projekt für europa von ska
keller in 30 sekunden
diese wahl ist eine klima wahl und wir
sehen die vielen jungen menschen die auf
die straße gehen und für ihre zukunft
streiten
und sie fordern uns auch endlich etwas
zu tun und wir müssen etwas tun wir
können das tun wir wissen was zu tun ist
aber wir brauchen mut und es braucht
veränderung und es braucht eine kraft im
europäischen parlament die für
klimaschutz 1 steht für datenschutz und
für sozialen zusammenhalt und das wollen
wir tun als grüne das herzensprojekt von
nicola beer für europa in 30 sekunden
jetzt
1989 vor 30 jahren hatten wir einen
traum dass zusammenwächst was
zusammengehört doch das ist nicht so
einfach
ich glaube wir müssen uns heute alle in
ganz europa fragen wie wir diesen traum
von damals jetzt gibt in wirklichkeit
bringen
mein europa ist ein europa wo
zusammenwächst was zusammengehört damit
menschen in diesem europa für sich
persönlich selbstbestimmte zukunft haben
ich glaube
wir haben in dieser stunde gesehen und
gespürt dass nicht jeder mit jedem gut
freund ist und wird der hier am tisch
steht und dass es auch keine natürlichen
koalition ohne weiteres gibt und große
gegensätze aber das war ja auch der sinn
der übung dass man die unterschiede
sieht und in dem sinne danke ich ihnen
ein vier und bitte noch mal für einen
grossen applaus
für dich greifbare runde auch von mir
vielen dank an die zuschauer im studio
und ihnen noch einen schönen abend
[Applaus]